it's a heavy topic to to uh try to
navigate how do you tell your story but
I got a lot of Amnesia from my childhood
I don't remember a lot I remember some
you know stuff comes back to me and I'm
like oh yeah that happened you know that
happened I remember doing this and this
but to be real it's it's like it's
another life you know it's something
I I lived through but I didn't live
through it was just a whole nother life
right and
I
am learning through through recovering
and getting myself whole and everything
that I that I can block out a lot
but I can't actually but the effects
what's underneath it it always stays and
that's what it's about it's unpacking
that and processing it
but um some of my earliest childhood
memories I guess I'll just start there
it was uh my earliest childhood memories
I remember being
um in bed and and getting naked and
calling my mom into my room because I
wanted I wanted to be touched and when I
say touch I wanted healthy touched but I
didn't know what was healthy and
unhealthy or whatever but I called it in
my room and she got into my bed and
my mom she started molesting me that was
some of my earliest memories and I don't
and I already knew the routine by then
I don't know how
far back it goes but this was around
second grade because I also remember
uh
I remember remembering it I remember
experiencing the body memories of uh
what happened in the classroom
um
and I didn't know what it was I didn't
know what it meant I just I was I was
distraught and
I remember
uh
my mom
she was a
trying to penetrate me and I would
imagine these decks of cards like cement
cards just blocking falling and just
trying to separate that
from uh from me and then I remembered
her her head in the back of my neck and
this is this is in the classroom and I'd
like got up and I started to like trying
to
swatted away with the fly and I started
walking
around the classroom and that's all I
remember and uh
those memories would come back to me
every several years
and I didn't know what they meant
at all you know
I remember in high school
um
when I was
I was uh
I'd say that was the worst period of my
life that that's
hard
to go back to high school
um
because there's so much going on in me
the
PTSD and the dissociation
part of it was I wanted to die so bad so
the worst worst depression
is like
feeling
so
yeah this is hard
um
I'll just share just dissociation it's
like
you're sitting on your couch in your
back your brain watching life happen
before your eyes but it's a movie it
doesn't really matter you know you you
can say stuff to some people
that are good and they respond a certain
way or you can say stuff to people that
are bad and they respond respond a
certain way but none of it
really matters because it's not a real
it's just it's just a movie
but
I remember
thinking in high school and I that
that I was a I was a demon from hell
put on Earth to be
tormented by people
that my life was
for their amusement
and then when I die I was going back to
hell
and that I figured it out
and so what I wanted to do
was that
kill innocence I literally wanted to
kill innocence because that's how I
would get my power back
and that was a scary scary [__] place
to be
because I started to fantasize hard
about
literally uh shooting up my school
and
for no Rhyme or Reason other than the
place I was at mentally from all the
incest and all the torment I went
through throughout my grade school
so
I guess I guess I'll backtrack a bit
um
in in some ways I was a normal kid
because I went to a private grade school
private high school I played Sports all
year round and I hung out with uh
uh I guess you could say mostly healthy
people from good families who I like I
like being a part of that you know I
liked uh and that was a good anchor and
everything
um
but within the house and everything it
was uh
again I don't I don't remember anything
like I can tell you throughout my entire
life up to
graduating high school I I get in
arguments with my mom we'd just be
shouting so much vitriol and hatred but
I can't tell you a single thing what it
was about I don't remember anything what
it's about
I just remember that I'm living these
two lives but I'm being pulled and
pulled in like two different directions
like
I want to be a normal kid
but at the same time there's this part
of me that's just this sickness is just
growing and it's just this demented
anger and hatred and darkness is growing
and
I remember experiencing body memories
of actually being
raped by my mom in like the fifth grade
classroom and again I have no
recollection of what that's about but
pieces just come together and
I and my life starts to make sense you
know
so
yeah I'm sorry I got it I'm getting
overwhelmed I gotta chill for a second
you say the classroom what's that when
you say you were raped in the classroom
no it wasn't in the classroom it was at
home but but like your body stores that
stuff right and and you you remember and
it feels like it's happening again but
you don't know what it's about
you know like I'd have I'd have dreams
of um
I I guess I'll just I'll just share this
story
um give you an idea what my mom was like
so this is
God I don't know how old I was I
it was I was definitely less than fifth
grade but I remember
I was
playing a game with my mom where I don't
know I I would I'd call her names that
you know kids would call
your parents you know just
like butt head and stuff like that and
she would kind of Chase me around the
house and I'd run away and laugh and run
away and laugh and things like that
and I remember she started to look in
her face she started to to change and
everything she started to switch and she
got this very demented sadistic look in
her eyes
where
it it scared the [__] out of me honestly
I remember this time I'm terrified and
I'm just running away from her and
running away from her
and I run up the steps and she chases me
up to the steps
and I run to my uh dad trying to get
help like I'm like [__] like I didn't
say but I've just run to my dad I'm
terrified like I wanted safety so I get
to my dad and he just beelines off in
the corner and goes like nope nope nope
and he doesn't he doesn't want to get
involved she just he's a he's a coward
you know he ran away and that crushed me
you know so my mom she starts hitting me
and then I don't remember what happened
next but I remember I think this is the
same memory running to my bed
and my mom's chasing me and I jump on my
bed and she jumps up and she straddles
me
and
we start escalating back and forth in
threats and So eventually I put my my
thumb over uh eye socket her eyeball and
I say like I'm gonna gouge your eye out
and she just Smiles at me
and
event and after a second of standoff or
whatever I removed my hand and she comes
down on the side of my face
and she starts licking it
and so
occasionally I'd have dreams about that
but I didn't know what it meant but when
I wake up the side of my face would be
wet so that's like the body memory where
your body just stores this trauma and
you don't and I don't I don't like I
don't know what it's about but it but
it's like it's happening again
I don't know why but it's real like it's
my like literally the air feels
different on this side of my face when
it happens or you literally like if
you're being scratched you literally
feel the scratch but you but I don't I
don't know what it's about like why am I
having these These Memories why am I
experiencing this I don't know anything
what what's going on what the root of it
is or anything but like I said like
sometimes when you're in the when I'm
would feel
heavy
and just trying to figure out what the
[__] is wrong with my life these things
would pop up but I didn't know what they
meant or anything like that and then I
just push it back down but the effects
of everything would stay there
so around around seven and eighth grade
the the side of me from all the
repression started to come through and
I go to high school
I start to uh
you know I I get cut from baseball you
know I tried out it was baseball was my
life and
it was all all good you know just
because other kids were better than me
but
I just I just started to sink like I
didn't know how to connect with people I
didn't know how to relate to people and
that's when the numbness started to kick
in I started to get very numb
feeling nothing like sometimes I
remember walking down the hall between
classes and just everybody's voice was
an echo like I couldn't even distinguish
what people were saying it was just I
was just completely out of it
and all this time I'm suffering and
miserable my parents
they're oblivious to it
and
I just start to sink in high school like
I people's people's laughter
I started to take it personally like
they were laughing at me
people's happiness
started to
it just became too much to bear it's
it's hard to explain but it's just
it's just like when you when you're
hungry right it's worse when you're
hungry next to a restaurant and people
are eating really good food you just
want it more
and it was like I just couldn't partake
in it
and that's when
suicide really started to take hold
um it's like the way I kind of described
it is it's like you have to buy in a
quicksand right at the in a pit
and the the slopes of the pit you can't
they're I they're too
they're like ice i can't get any
traction to climb out so I'd struggle
and then I'd just give up but then I'd
get into the quicksand I'd start to sink
and sink and sink and then I'd struggle
to climb out of it and then and then I
try to climb out again so I just
constantly kind of went between those
two
uh that was my life
and that's when I'd start to put kind of
ropes under my chin in the basement
things like that
um I had a gun but it was didn't have
any bullets but I would
play with it I'd fantasize about
shooting people and then I'd always put
the gun in my mouth or under my chin and
squeeze the trigger we didn't have
bullets for it but that's what it was
that's what I did it was just it was
just an outlet it was just an outlet
um
the the physical abuse for my mom I'd
say stopped around fifth sixth grade but
I remember she tried to initiate it
again in high school she she had a
she would dissociate I don't know if she
had multiple personalities but she
definitely dissociate
and I remember I think I was in freshman
or sophomore year in high school
she she gets this vacant blank look on
her face like she just like smiled she'd
just be like but but no one was home
right and she'd just be like
a completely different person and I
remember she would just walked by and
she kept touching my arm and I'd snap
and I just just all this rage would
Bubble Up and I just I just point at her
and get really intense like like don't
[__] touch me energy
and she did that and and she ignored she
did it maybe like four times or
something like that and finally
something clicked in me and I and I said
told her I said look Mom I don't know
what's going on but um if you touch me
again I think I'm going to murder you
and then it and then I just kind of hit
me for a second like yeah I realized
that's what I was going to do and all
she said was okay and it stopped but she
uh
but
this but she she found subtle ways to
like
to do [__] like I'd be watching TV and
she'd stand in front of the TV and just
just bend over and point her crotch at
me
and I guess I want to clarify too you
know where I'm at right now I don't look
at myself as a victim I really don't
I've been I'm in a much better place
it's hard to kind of rehash these
memories but this is her [__] you know
it's not my [__] you know I just I just
kind of want to share this one of my
motivations for sharing this is it
always it always hurts me when when
people endure [__] from other people
and it causes them to lash inwards or
lash outwards and it's just like
don't
don't come don't continue their sickness
you know that's there's that's their
problem that's their issue it ain't mine
in any and it ain't yours either
you it's what they did is their [__]
but
do whatever you got to do but don't
continue it you know don't don't
continue it through you
so
anyways this is the stuff she did
um
finding ways to like
yeah bend over in front of the TV and
other [__] I guess I can let that go
but um
kind of forgot where I was at
um
but yeah High School is just [__] it was
just complete [__] but the underlying
theme of your mom's
strange Behavior was kind of sexual yeah
it was and I I blocked all that stuff
out because I didn't like I got I got
into kickboxing when I was a junior in
high school and I loved lifting weights
so I started to get some attention from
women and when it would come on I just
I'd freeze bad like I'd
I I wouldn't it was it was it was such a
bad freeze response
and I did again I thought I didn't know
if everyone dealt with this [__] or if
it's just me but I didn't know why but I
blocked all of it out but she had
definitely
she she definitely tried to really
re-initiate the abuse even up until I
was 25 before everything came out but I
got so I had to block everything out I
blocked everything out any type of
sexual energy I had to just block it out
and it just I had to go into denial you
know I honestly think it it saved me
from doing something terrible that I'd
regret you know I
many times man many many times dude I
wanted to I I remember being in high
school or college and standing behind
her in the kitchen with a [__] knife
and just trying to talk myself up to do
it like I'm so fortunate man to be where
I'm at like seriously dude
but I blocked it all out
and emotions are just emotions they're
not nothing to be ashamed of same with
thoughts you never acted out anything no
no no no
um
if y'all if y'all went through my life
of a comb if I you know I
I wouldn't get arrested
it's just by the grace of God that I'm
here straight up like by the grace of
God I'm here I'm doing pretty good
you know you're working I'm working I
got some money saved I don't drink
I don't even like to drink I do once in
a while but it's just [__] it's just
the remnants of uh something I thought I
have to do I don't like smoking weed
you're resilient Mary
I've been working out and eating healthy
is my addiction I just feel good I just
I just think life's getting better and
better I'm very optimistic what 38 38
yeah 38. are you an only child no I got
a brother older brother 20 months did he
go through anything like that when I
told him he uh he said he thought about
it for like three hours and decided he
wasn't but
with all due respect to him he I mean he
has his own struggles too you don't you
don't come out of that unharmed I don't
know what exactly he went through
I know a little but
I love them and I hope the best for him
he believed you
I don't think no one does my family I
don't think they can
I don't think they can
but he don't
I don't know they don't know what's your
relationship like with your parents now
I have I've seen my mom twice since 2009
whenever no 2010 when everything came
out and I and I got out of the mental
hospital
I lived at home for about three months I
thought we were going to be a happy
family like oh I finally realized what
happened Mom it's okay I forgive you you
can finally let the weight off your back
and we can be that family I always
dreamed of like I was so naive
and uh
my dad
to be blunt is in many respects and
utter failure like but
but not he um my mom I've seen when I
last saw her I saw her twice and since
2010 for a total of about five minutes
I spoke to her on a phone on the phone
for a brief period of time and I was
like hardcore Christian thought that God
needed me to do that or some [__]
like I was a good Christian I had to
forgive her I had to I was just
misguided and [__] like that
um well I don't talk to her anymore I
don't think I will ever again honestly
I've gotten piece of that my dad my
relationship with my dad is strained
because it's mostly
me feeling sorry for him because he's
getting old he's kind of losing his
memory a bit
and he's and it's it's tough because
he's very needy lonely and it's kind of
a burden to me
and in many ways I do it just because I
feel it's a good thing to do
but as I get as I grow and I and I
really learn how to connect with people
and realize like people are
many people are so there's so many good
people out there there's so many good
people out there and
you and I'm learning how to open up and
be receptive to that goodness and
everything and learning my own value and
how to give back at my own worth man it
makes life incredible
and the more I Branch onto that the more
I just got to let go so part of me
honestly feels like forgiven my dad and
moved on from that but I have no desire
to speak to him anymore what do you
think your mom went through as a child
in her life she was uh
I know there were there were Hillbillies
they hate that word but [__] it
um they were there's a lot of violence
in their house a lot of mental illness a
lot of [__] like that my grandma was
horribly abusive she'd tell me stories
when I was a kid about how they'd fight
um I think my uncle molested my mom
um
that was kind of dropped and my mom
would tell me stories like they would
fight and she'd get hit in the head with
the high heel shoes and plead and just
[__] like that they'd fight all the time
and yell
and they were and even when I was adult
like they were crazy like there's a lot
of uh alcohol abuse in that side of the
family a lot of uh
uh spousal abuse and just just Insanity
man in general where did she grow up uh
Mansfield Ohio Rural Ohio
my dad was from there or another area
kind of uh Butler another kind of rural
area
um
that's that
they're um
yeah
they moved to the city
I remember my mom kind of trying to get
the accent out of me a bit because they
had that
that fur you know we don't it's not fur
it's for you know you've got to talk
proper
and stuff like that and I didn't even
know but then I then I read the book
hillbilly eulogy and it put a lot of
sense in my life actually I'm like oh
okay that makes sense that's what
they're about all right but so oh
there's a lot of Shame around that but I
don't know I kind of like my accent and
everything you know you grew up in Ohio
yeah Columbus Columbia is a city what's
that went to private school went to
private high school parents paid for
college like 95 percent of it
graduated never used my bottom of my
class but I graduated that was the big
thing so your parents weren't all bad no
they did provide and if I can give them
credit for that I never went hungry and
I had a place to sleep realistically you
know thank you for pointing that out for
real it's I always had a place to sleep
and I had food
and I did get a good education that
helped me out a lot
so
no they weren't all bad
and that's part of the confusion too the
the trying to reconcile everything
feeling guilty over this you know
feeling guilty that
how long or how often did it go on
the which part the sexual abuse I don't
know when it stopped I'd say fifth grade
I don't know how early it was I'd say
kindergarten to fifth grade but
afterwards
there's a lot of mental and emotional
abuse like my mom
like talking to me about her period one
day and I didn't want to [__] hear it
and just sick [__] like that that really
messes with your brain the fact that she
kept trying to
get into it again yeah I think you were
25. I don't know this was this was in
high school I don't know her motivation
I think she was just uh
she was just an abusive person I think
she was
I don't know she was a full-on
psychopath but I think she was just a
straight up abusive person
and and that's what abusive people do
they like to get they like to hurt
people they they take sadistic pleasure
and
that was her
sadistic pleasure in it I really believe
that is your
ability to break it down and understand
it helped calm you down
a little what what the only thing it
does is helping me understand it helps
me process it because I've never been
able to solve emotional issues mentally
but what it does get gets me to a point
where I can face it
I feel like I can face it I can talk to
somebody I can face it you know and I I
can
when I feel like there's something I got
to do that scares me whether it be
going on a retreat or
in a really process the emotions it
mentally trying to understand my
problems just gets me to a point where I
can't BS my way out of it I can't
through fear so it's just a yes or no
I'm either going to do it or I'm not
going to do it
thankfully I usually choose courage and
I do it
thankfully so
but understanding it
understanding it I don't I don't think
is necessary
as long as you can feel it you're good
you know you that's how you heal
I honestly God hope if if one person
heals hears this and thanks man like
they're not alone and they can really
change
that's it right there that's that's just
kind of what I want honestly
because I like I said man I feel so
fortunate and blessed man I I've had to
leave some people behind yeah but
but I don't I don't know what it is that
that makes me just want to keep going
other than this
overwhelming desire that I just cannot
believe that because of
a set of circumstances in my life that
happened that I'm doomed or I'm destined
or I'm faded to live this subpar
[__] I don't believe that at all and
I'll go out I'll go I'll die I'll die
before I quit
I I just I I don't I was a victim but I
don't see how I'm a victim now I don't
see how I'm a victim now from my past
there's [__] I gotta work through but
sometimes people go through this kind of
stuff and it makes them stronger and
more resilient and more loving in the
end that's I it does it does it helps
everybody takes the wrong path yeah
not everybody does do that right path no
some people quit
and they give up on themselves or they
give up on life and they resign you know
and that's
sad
but
I can honestly say there are things I'm
that I'm proud about who I am looking
back these past 12 years and what
recovery's been I got a lot of faith I
know I'm very strong I got some good
friends who I jokingly say are normies
that was what we called and I'm able to
actually give them good advice and and
be there for them because
uh eventually you see other people deal
with the same problems just on different
degrees
I do genuinely love people and I help
them out and I do a good job I took care
of people with special needs and
disabilities for a while and I took that
job extremely seriously
because
in a way it was like they were me you
know and and and you see their needs and
everything like
like there's this one dude with a
schizophrenia I talked to him normal
conversations but he'd tell me stories
about how his neighbors are trying to
like to grass on fire and things like
that and he needed to be cleaned and
everything and when I cleaned this is
descriptive there'd be
complete after he uh went number two you
know and he wore diapers and stuff and
sometimes I have to clean that up you
know
and other staff members wouldn't do a
good job there'd be like a lot of crust
in there and it's just like that's a
human being who feels it too you know
who who feels the same discomfort so
you know I'd make sure
I just do my best you know and that
that's kind of how everything I've been
through and the recovery has changed me
it's like it does make me very
empathetic
and
um
compassionate too I really I really do
in many ways like like the man I am now
yeah I think understanding yeah how
people got into these situations or yeah
this mental
damage yeah
is the key and it makes you more
empathetic it makes you more
compassionate
yeah it helps you heal helps others I
remember when I lived in a homeless
shelter hearing the stories of the other
people there it's just like
I can't get mad at these people at all
you know I mean of course I'm there too
but the tragedy that they went through
was like astronomical you know a good a
good friend of mine there he was a
little younger than me he grew up in the
ghetto and he was a gang banger than a
drug dealer and here I am this college
educated white boy with this six foot
six black dude who was a pimp drug
dealer and we'd play basketball and talk
and stuff and straight up like I I love
the dude you know we just connected on
such a deep level you know and he was
such a I'm so grateful he he opened up
to me but I and I asked him one time I'm
like how many people you've seen shot
and he's like I can't tell you I'm like
how many murders you've seen he's like
I've seen five murders
and all the insanity shared it's just
like this whole Generations growing up
with PTSD and these [__] inner cities
and I had no idea
Grant what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
you have to believe in yourself and
don't quit
even when things bottom out
you might be at the edge of a
breakthrough it might be at the edge of
just trying to change your mind about
your circumstances and decide something
different or maybe you're holding on to
something too tight but you'd never quit
and you have to believe in yourself and
you're far stronger than you can imagine
like I
I'm jumping around a bit
but when I moved out of the uh my
parents house after everything came out
I remember
I remember I got my own apartment I
remember I'd lie on the floor sometimes
into fetal position because I so I
thought I was I couldn't even work at
McDonald's as such I I was so
incompetent I couldn't even work at
McDonald's
and
I get Comfort Myself by saying all the
problems you know I was living off my
savings I thought
don't worry about your problems managers
train tracks nearby you can drink and
smoke weed and just end it all and
you'll be fine and now I'd Comfort
myself that way so I mean it was
literally like
trying to
bring myself up from the bottom up and
through this whole trauma and stuff I
wanted to go back to my parents for
comfort and reassurance but I knew I
couldn't
because they're the problem
I guess I guess I'll continue so I
graduated from high school eventually uh
sucked senior year sat alone by myself
during lunch humiliating it was so
utterly humiliating I was so out of it
oh [__] man I was uh this this is this
is embarrassing but [__] it I'd be
sitting there by myself
and about 10 feet over there where where
the Freshman girls would begin to sit I
just had nobody man I was so [__] out
of it by this point
oh God it was [__] dude it was such [__]
but I graduated went to college started
college and it got got a little better
and everything like that
uh
[__]
yeah this is hard I ain't gonna lie this
is hard but I you know
but um
couldn't figure out why I couldn't
connect with people and relate to people
I'd still that numbing heaviness you
know you're I'm still walking around the
world talking to people trying to
understand them from an intellectual
Point not able to open up not able to
connect and even know what emotions were
and I'm starting to understand people
but the good thing I got going for me is
I'm kickboxing like five days a week and
I'm exercising I love the feeling
afterwards
so
anyways
at some point
all the stress broke me and I thought I
was [__] up I thought I had the
perfect parents and they were so [__]
up for tolerating and they're so perfect
for tolerating a [__] up person like
me I just it just broke me
so I'm just going through life now this
Meek scared quiet subdued person
but I'm also doing kickboxing and it's
just a good thing in my life right and
uh
and
I meet a girl she likes me kind of
and we spend the night together nothing
happened Beyond holding each other but
it felt so good
and that unlocked something I didn't get
a second date out of it but it unlocked
something
because I mean it's not just about for
me at least this is what I went through
poor me like I I really
want to share positive you know the
positive stuff I don't I want to go
heavy I I feel like going heavy is okay
because people go through such heavy
[__] you know and I don't want people to
feel like they're alone
uh but there's some really good stuff
too that happened when I started to get
my life together and everything like
that
um
oh [__]
so I guess long story short man all the
everything I went through you know so
it's had to have its own voice it came
out I started to feel so much guilt and
shame and
I literally had a psychotic breakdown
over the course of a couple months I
prayed I I didn't like who I was so I
prayed to God I'm like I want to trial
by fire because I don't feel like a man
I want to feel like a man so give me a
trial by fire
and all this stuff this guilt and this
shame and all this pressure started to
come up over the course of a couple
months
and
um
at one point I remember I thought the TV
was talking to me telling me sending me
messages like legitimately I was it was
just stress was unbelievable
I'm uh trying to I'm going to classes at
this time and then uh at one point I
stopped eating I stopped eating for
about three days and I just became gaunt
and
I
was I believed that my soul I was
getting better
um but I I was I just literally lost my
mind and I shared all this personal
information with uh
with uh actually that random girl I I
just constructed something in my mind
and it was
and when I realized what had happened
that was it like that was it I just
couldn't go on anymore I gave up I tried
I just didn't have any more to give
so how everything came out was once it
happened
I I was like muttering and talking to
myself just to stress I I took a small
dress in my room and I threw it against
the wall and I smashed it and I just
went down and blew up at my parents my
mom freaked out she left and I went to
my backyard
and I smoked a bunch of weed because I
knew that I was going to
going to act out what uh
act out my emotions right
and
it's definitely heavy but sure I this is
this is when I
I guess you could say The Dark Knight of
the Soul so I and how everything came
out so I smashed up my room then
I smoked a bunch of weed because I knew
I'd act on my emotions by then and I'm
in my backyard and I told God I'm like
look if you don't tell me your plan for
my life tonight I'm going to kill myself
and so I went in my dad's watching TV
and I'm freaking the [__] out at this
moment I got this big glass bottle of
vodka and sleeping pills and a rope that
I was had previously tied I was going to
hang myself in the basement
and
the the the feeling and all I remember
is
the feeling that I had to disappear like
there's this big hole in my chest and
all my energy was caving in and I had to
disappear and I couldn't go back I I
just I couldn't I couldn't give I
couldn't and go on any longer I just had
to I had to
I just couldn't you know I gave up and
so I remember thinking
I'm freaking out my dad's on the couch
he doesn't know what to do I'm thinking
okay I gotta go
uh
I gotta go in the basement hang myself
now drink it
take it hang myself and I remember a
thought a thought came in my head that
said no if you do that she's going to
call the cops you got to hit him with
the bottle until he stops moving and
then you can do it
and that's when that's when
it got heavy really heavy because that
was
the driving force in me my next emotion
was to do that
and I don't want to say
my life flashed before my eyes but I
remember but like I the way I described
it is when you watch a movie right and
there's like these certain red flags
that pop up right all of a sudden you
get to the end and those little red
flags are the actual truth and Knots
what's going on the person's being
gaslit so I remember and I just remember
thinking I never believed I'd live to be
30 years old and all these other things
had led to this moment and I didn't want
to do it
but I I didn't couldn't go back right
and
in my and then in my mind Mike I might
help help help and a thought said just
go over sit next to your dad tell me say
please tell me I'm all right please tell
me I'll be okay
and I didn't want to do that either
because it was like
vulnerable and scary and I'm like I
don't do that I'm like and then thought
I said no you have to decide what are
you going to do right now right now so I
ended up thankfully going over and
saying that and he rubbed my back and
said that and every the emotions went
away just like that
and I knew I was going to be all right
and next day I start this outpatient
program at the hospital and we would get
in touch with our emotions and things
like that I remember feeling emotions
for like the first time like oh this is
great like I could identify my emotions
and I remember
tell him after the gym one day telling
myself that I was molested by my mom and
that's why I was the way I was because
it brought me Comfort even though I had
no memories it just brought me Comfort
and so anyways I I'm doing this
outpatient program at the hospital I'm
getting in touch with my emotions I
remember one night just this
overwhelming urge or Voice or something
like that
came up
and
after two and we said this is what
happened to you
and it just felt right I just knew it
even though I had no memory I just knew
it
I go to the uh
the the hospital next day
and they're asking me
just to check in and I and I wanted to
say what I believed but I couldn't say
it and I just started shaking all over
like it was like this little ball of
energy that started to like shoot up my
body it would go through my legs just
ping pong and rebound all throughout my
body and wherever it would go I'd shake
you know I'd shake right
and
um
and and one of the guys there asked me
he made me say it I said it and I'm just
like
freaking out you know
and he asked me if I was a harm to
myself or someone else and I said yeah I
might kill my mom like I didn't know
like I didn't know if I would or not
I said well I can't let you leave I'm
like okay so I was in
the lockdown part of the hospital for a
bit for a week and then there all the
memories came back
and that's when stuff clicked and made
sense and I kind of realized and that
started recovery it's just it's been the
focal point of my life
have you seen a therapist uh right now
yeah I am I've been on and off you know
I've been on and off right now I do uh
uh something called surrogate therapy
where
I basically retrain my body how to let
people get close to me and touch me
to enjoy the process
and of moving towards sex and everything
like that and it's been great it's been
helping me out a lot I've done a lot
dude I've done a lot
and for the most part I'm pretty good
now I would think this has got to impact
your sexual relationships
it makes me enjoy women more helps me uh
I feel the energy like every every woman
I meet you know their energy is
different you know sometimes they're
bubbly sometimes they're girly sometimes
it's just different I enjoy it like it's
just it's just a fun appreciative like I
can really appreciate
women now that wasn't always the case
before that no I didn't feel anything I
didn't feel anything what what what
would happen before was I would meet
somebody I like and as soon as we got
close I just shut down and then I'd feel
a disgust I'd feel very disgusted at
them
and I I thought I was gay like even
though I never like been attracted to
men I thought I was gay because why else
am I feeling disgusted towards women
right
um but now it's helped a lot dude
but not it's just just learning to feel
comfortable in my body
um it took me a while to Define recovery
as being able to speak my truth
and feeling safe in my own body
and
um at times I I legitimately experienced
that
it's
yeah
it's done a lot you know I know I know
we're short on time but I could talk for
another 45 minutes about all the
experiences I had you know faith faith
is extremely important too for me at
least because I wouldn't be able to take
the risk I took like I moved out of
state twice I've had to give up my stuff
twice
but I always know things are going to be
all right and I got uh somebody or
higher power taken out taken looking
over me you know mine's Jesus
I don't
particularly feel comfortable at the
church a lot
but
things that happened in my life just
have led me to believe that that's
who's looking out for me and gives me a
lot of comfort
um
for real it does I've been I've been
hurt in the church I know a lot of
people I met people who have to so
if you have I'm sorry for real it's
there's a lot of toxicity in there but
but if I'm just being real with you that
helped me kind of
get to a point where I got a lot of
faith in optimism and hope for the
future and at times I genuinely like who
I am and what I've been through and the
recovery effort I put in these past 12
years that helped me get to a point
where I got I I'm proud like I'm Legit
proud of who I am like the resilience
and
just the grit and the toughness and the
work I put into uh
it's being strong you know it's it's
feels good you know I I feel good about
who I am
and being able to open up more and and
connect it's
I just feel like my life's getting
better for real
the dark days aren't dark they're not
hopeless they're opportunities to grow
there are opportunities to toughen
yourself
nothing to be there's lessons there's
lessons that are in there that's how you
get wise is through suffering there's no
other way that I know of
so I wouldn't I wouldn't trade really
anything sometimes I wish things were
different but right now I wouldn't trade
anything because I feel like my roots
are so deep right now
that I wanna
I wanna see what I can grow into bro
you know I wouldn't I wouldn't trade a
lot I just wish people believe they're
not alone and don't give up on yourself
try again why not you know you're going
to die one day anyways why not why not
go out knowing that you didn't quit and
you didn't resign on yourself or quit on
yourself ever
don't do that thank you